what's up guys back by popular demand we
are doing another camera phone test now
we did the s22 ultra camera phone test a
lot of you like that thank you guys for
so much for the comments and for the
likes and for watching so now we're
going to pit this phone against two of
the other top in android phones when it
comes to cameras the all-new xiaomi 12
pro and the oppo find x5 pro that's a
partnered with hasselblad
which phone is the best when it comes to
cameras
we're about to find out we're gonna do
front-facing cameras we're gonna do
photography we're gonna do video we're
gonna do all that great stuff so let's
get down to it give a big thanks to each
of these companies samsung singapore of
course xiaomi singapore and oppo
singapore having said that these are our
thoughts and our thoughts only by the
way if you haven't subscribed to the
channel please do so and like this video
it helps us out a lot all right
i'm gonna give you a cliff notes version
of this review just in case you don't
have time to watch this entire video but
i hope you guys do also put chapter
markers throughout this so you can skip
to the portion that is more relevant to
you but i will say this
each of these phones have some standout
features the other phones do not have if
there's one clear winner out of all this
it's a tough one to say but i will say
that uh samsung's got four cameras
versus three on the other two phones but
does that mean the four is better than
three
we're gonna find out
but i will say
samsung has really impressed me in this
battle with that let's test these phones
out first with the front-facing cameras
okay our first one we're going to start
off with is the xiaomi 12 pro now
here's the thing about the xiaomi and
the oppo they only have 1080p cameras on
the front-facing camera this they do
have 4k like the samsung so right there
the samsung's already ahead but it's not
always about the resolution because
nowadays on tick tock and instagram
we're only using 1080 anyway we can't
use 4k nonetheless let's see how this
performs we're going to be doing video
here front facing camera
screen recording as well
now
let's go into we can turn on hdr if we
want
we're going to turn down
all the beauty modes
because it gets absolutely insane
okay hdr right off the bat it softens my
skin way too much
killing that want to be more natural
like this you're going to see my age
there we go now we're in 1080 30 frames
per second on this and uh just going to
walk in and talking and testing this out
see how it exposes in the background of
this now in the back you're going to see
that the sky is pretty much blown out
but when we look out there you can still
see clouds
so
yeah it's a little bit overexposed but i
do look i'm in focus
and yeah stabilization is pretty good as
i'm walking here and i'm talking
everything looks really stable there's
zaki and zino right there what's up guys
yes yeah i mean it's clear
pretty sharp
no she's all but a little bit brighter
than i would expect i would expect a
little bit more of a tone down for the
back end so see the sky completely white
but the sky is not white we don't have
white skies so that is the xiaomi 12 pro
now another a couple new features in the
xiaomi 12 pro of course is hlg and hdr
10 plus when you're doing video with the
front-facing camera so
hdr 10 plus may not work so well with
premiere as well we're editing with
right now at geek culture so we're going
to try hlg here and see how this looks
now it's in hlg
right looking at the screen here really
not much difference than the standard uh
front-facing camera of course when we
look into it uh
in post we'll see the difference but
again the sky is completely blown out
there's no clouds no detail whatsoever
i'm exposed correctly so it's exposing
for the face for most than anything else
which is fine but if you do want to get
that dynamic range you're going to miss
it a little bit now i am seeing a little
bit of blue in the clouds just a tint of
blue but it's still not what i would
expect to see out of this so
i'll say exposure for the face is great
the rest of it however
it's only so-so so we're taking a couple
photos here with the front-facing camera
as we need to do because we also take
photos right right so here's a standard
photo and let's just take a
shot of this
that's without hdr let's turn on hdr
we'll see what the difference is
and then we're going to go to portrait
mode
it does a pretty decent job it does look
a little synthetic but again
it's not too bad and of course you can
adjust the bokeh to your liking so you
can make it much more severe turn it
down a little bit i always keep it
around like f5 to 6.3 thereabouts it
looks a bit like that looks more natural
on smartphones versus like f2 or f4
where it can look a little bit too fake
uh but it does a decent job not too bad
so now we're testing the front-facing
camera with the opal find x5 pro we'll
be doing video then photos okay in video
we're going to turn off the ai for this
a second uh we're going to turn off the
uh stabilization we're at 1080p at 30fps
now because you do not get 4k with the
oppo or the xiaomi so let's kick it off
with video here
now right off the bat this video looks a
little bit more
contrasty but
the sky's still blown out
still blown out not seeing much detail
not much dynamic range um
again what we see on the screen is not
always what we get when we look out on
the computer screen because sometimes
things will change so looking at it
right now it looks pretty decent it's
not too bad uh let's make sure the
screen brightness is up
the sunrise is all the way up
i would say the xiaomi looked a little
bit brighter than the oppo but this is
not too bad as well
okay now i've turned on ai and now the
sky is exposed beautifully you can see
the clouds in the background everything
has better dynamic range
even with the skin softening turned off
it looks like my skin is a little bit
soft in here with the oppo but the ai is
doing a better job i think
than the the standard version if you
want more dynamic range more you know
detail in your background you can see
the palm trees you can see the clouds
this all looks really good the
stabilization on this is probably not as
good as the xiaomi off the back but i
haven't turned on stabilization on the
front facing camera yet we'll do that in
just a second but overall
i have to say the image quality looks
pretty good now when i turn on
stabilization the ai goes off so you
have a choice ai which you get better
dynamic range or stabilization but as i
turn around here the stabilization
it's pretty stable and it looks pretty
good i have to say so uh
i mean the background's not even
bouncing i'm bouncing this is pretty
almost surreal
there's zacky right there
what's up jackie what's up what's up as
you can see the exposure
it's a little bit delayed in terms of
how it uh responds to zacky there's me
but the sky is completely blown out here
when we're using stabilization all right
now we're going to be testing out the
photo modes here on the oppo find x5
pro's front-facing camera now here's the
thing i'm turning off hdr first and
this is a little bit more exposed than
the xiaomi uh i would say
a little bit more than i would like it
to be it could bring it down a little
bit now you probably can do this a
little bit in post let me turn off all
this uh
all these retouching aspects here
because there's so many options you can
you can tweak in this phone you can
change your eye size your nose your
cheeks your jawline you can become a
different looking person out of a
front-facing camera out of these uh
these phones it's quite insane all right
let's try it out
you hear that click
that's the hasselblad click because this
is a partnership with hasselblad so
we'll get into the pro camera section in
just a minute when we talk about that
but you're getting a lot of those
hasselblad those that that ui the sounds
that's in this opel find x5 pro which is
cool i'm a big fan of hasselblad and you
get the orange shutter release button
just like on your x1d and x1 d2
and also the other hasselblad cameras as
well that orange shutter button when you
see that on a camera you know you're
talking quality
[Music]
look at the end results hdr sky is
balanced out i look really good i have
to say the hr does a decent job when it
comes to photos
and then now let's go to portrait mode
turn off all that uh
beauty stuff here
portrait mode
i will say this the colors are very
natural coming out of this camera
it is a little bit more exposed than the
xiaomi but the colors for the front
facing look more
say true to life
that's part of the hasselblad uh
technology that's coming into play here
so
yeah i'm happy with it looks really good
okay now let's go to the samsung s22
ultra
okay now we're testing out the front
facing camera for video on the samsung
s22 ultra now a couple things to note of
in terms of the feel of the phone this
is a very large phone i prefer the feel
of the oppo find x5 pro and the xiaomi
12 pro over this in terms of feel
because when you are taking photos and
videos with your smartphone you want a
phone that feels very secure in your
hands
this feels very slippery now it doesn't
have a case like the other two have
because those come with cases inside the
box you have to pay extra for that but
this is a larger phone overall so that's
something to take note of if you're
really into videography and photography
and you want a good feeling phone this
may be a deal breaker for you but it's
about image quality right right let's
talk about video for a second now with
the samsung you get the 4k 60p on the
front-facing camera now you do not get
this with the xiaomi or the oppo so the
samsung already wins in that department
but as i mentioned earlier if you're
using tik-tok or instagram reels or
stories you're not shooting in 4k you
are shooting in 1080 or 720 for that
matter so
4k do you need it well it depends on how
you want to use the front-facing camera
if you're going to be combining this
with other footage let's say for a
youtube video and you want everything in
4k this will come in handy if you're
just doing it for instagram or for
tick-tock it really doesn't matter
anyway let's try this off in the basic
settings first we're turning off hdr
we're turning off uh stabilization we're
just gonna go straight out of camera
with the front facing at fhd 30 fps
looking at this right now i'm still
getting that same blown out sky when you
have hdr turned off okay but i will say
this on the samsung my face looks a
little bit more detailed than it did on
the oppo or the xiaomi 12 pro but that's
just looking at the display right here
we'll have to look on the computer
screen to give you the full
results on that i will say though it
does expose more for everything else the
face is not as exposed or as bright as
it is on the xiaomi or the oppo as well
so everyone's going to have their own
personal preference you may feel this is
more natural to see you can see the sky
you can see the blue in the sky where's
the other two you could not see that
unless hdr was turned on but you can see
it here so that's a tip to samsung on
this but overall looks good no
stabilization i'm walking right now and
even without that the stabilization is
pretty good i just say we'll turn that
on a second so you can see the
difference but overall i would say
there's a better balance to this image
than the xiaomi and the oppo find x5 pro
okay let's turn on hdr and let's turn on
stabilization to see if there's a
difference okay so when we turn on
stabilization you are going to get a
little bit of a crop in on your image
which happens on most cameras so it's
not a big deal on that now with hdr
looking at the display here my face is a
bit darker because it's exposing for the
sky and the face so you do you do lose a
little bit of that brightness in the
face again you can fix that in post but
it is something to take note of
stabilization is much improved though uh
but you know this is what's interesting
about it i mean there are no right or
wrong on this it depends on your
personal preference some people will
like this natural look
and some people will say look i prefer a
brighter face and i don't care about the
back uh you know the background so if
that's the case then you can opt for the
other two as well but here's the thing
that i did notice on these phones is
that actually on the samsung you don't
have all the settings on the top like
you do on the xiaomi or the opal so to
get into this it's a it's a two-step
process we have to tap on settings then
tap on those selections versus on the
oppo and the xiaomi it's right up there
on the top menu bar you can actually
just select what you want there and get
it right into your settings much easier
so maybe this is something you can
customize in the samsung i don't know
but as it stands right now
it uh seems that the the other two give
you the better options right off the bat
okay let's take some photos here with
the samsung s22 ultra and see how they
compare to this xiaomi and oppo
with no hdr
very detailed very nice image quality i
have to say the front facing camera on
this is very impressive um
a little bit more contrasty than the
opal find x5 and it's right up there
with the xiaomi so i see the xiaomi and
the samsung are very similar but i gotta
say this is a really good front-facing
camera for photography now let's uh try
it with
hdr on
and see how this looks
not too bad i mean the sky is okay let's
do another shot here to see if there's a
difference with the sky in the
background
okay hdr does kick in you do see all the
clouds in the background it almost looks
a little synthetic it almost looks too
good but uh it does work and let's try
portrait mode to see if there's a
difference
now it's taking the phone a little bit
of time to render the portrait mode and
here's the one thing about the the
samsung which i like is you can see the
individual hairs it does separate that
so it does look more natural than the
opal and the xiaomi so in portrait mode
i'll give it to the samsung anyway
that's it for the front facing camera
now let's go to the big boys the rear
cameras for video and photography so our
first test will be with the oppo find x5
pro now i'm personally excited about
this because i enjoy shooting with
hasselblad cameras and this is a
partnership with hasselblad so there are
some interesting specs to this camera
system you have three cameras you have a
50 megapixel wide angle lens 50
megapixel ultra wide and a 13 megapixel
telephoto you also do get macro moto on
the ultra wide uh lens like you would on
other camera systems out there
and uh of course it's part about the
mario silicone x processor in this so
it's a dedicated processor for the
photography and videography aspect of
this camera because it is using the snap
gen snapdragon 8 gen 1 chipset inside of
this but opal's trying to give you some
extra oomph with his photography and
videography out there so what we'll try
to do now is take some photos wide angle
ultra wide angle and telephoto we'll
shoot in raw plus and also in jpeg and
then we'll go inside we'll look at some
of the images on lightroom we'll talk
about the what i find in them in terms
of grading in terms of the out of the
camera image quality and all that great
stuff so with that let's get down to
taking some photos with the oppo find x5
pro
now what's interesting about this of
course is you're going to get
hasselblad's color science that's what
this touting is going to be inside this
camera system
and uh if you've ever seen hasselblad
colors they're just really unique reds
pop
greens pop as well i am noticing that
this is a little bit more saturated a
little bit more vibrant than what i'm
seeing with my naked eye right here so
this could be part and parcel with the
uh the whole processing that's going on
here and i'll teach their own of course
we can shoot in raw and then we can
change that i love the shutter sound of
this though isn't the shutter sound so
badass on this
the shutters the shutter sound makes
this camera system right here
okay let's go over to this wall here we
got a bright yellow wall now these are
sample images folks these are not going
to be anything that you're going to want
to post up and brag about but i just
want to kind of work with different
colors we're here at arab street in
singapore to try that out let's turn off
hdr on this
the yellows do come alive on this they
really do i would say it's pretty
accurate
maybe slightly a little bit more
brighter than what i'm seeing normally
out of the eye but okay it still looks
good and i think but you know here's the
thing on social media just a little bit
tip or trick for you guys out there if
you want more people to take notice of
your images on social media make them a
little more saturated a little more
vibrant it catches the eye so maybe
that's kind of what opal is doing here
baked into the image in the jpeg to make
it a little more appealing when you're
looking at this okay let's take a look
at this shot right here and we see we
got red we got yellows we got blues we
got greens with these benches here
there's a lot of colors happening here
now we're gonna go to 50 megapixel mode
on this
just out of camera right here this is
very impressive this is a beautiful how
it renders colors
now i'm going to go into wide angle
get this street right here this is a
really good testing area here because
then you get to see all the colors how
it handles
now here's the set inside the camera of
course when you're 50 megapixel you can
only use the ultra wide and the wide
because those are the only two lenses
that can do 50 megapixel now when you
turn that off then you have access to
all three as i mentioned the telephoto
is 13 megapixel the wide is uh 50 and
the ultra wide is 50. so turning that
off here let's just do telephoto
looking at the images here i would
definitely say the 50 megapixel mode
does make the images look a lot better
dynamic range everything else looks
fantastic on that there we go three
two one
and we're gonna go ultra wide
stay there a sec all right
i have to say not too bad it renders it
really quite well so we're talking about
portrait mode now on this camera of
course like most cameras use the
telephoto and the wide-angle lens now
when you're using portrait mode for wide
angle please be careful because it can
look really fake especially if you're
taking a picture of somebody it can look
like they're cut out and paste on the
background which is not how the photos
look like i mean unless you're shooting
at 0.95 and even then it can look a
little bit too much um but i will say
this looks relatively good i mean the
hairs cut out is what is nice you can
see the details in the strands of hair
which looks pretty realistic the colors
are awesome the skin tones out of the
oppo find x5 pro are fantastic you're
getting that hasselblad color science
which i love hasselblad's uh skin tones
by the way they're awesome and i've seen
that right right here with zacky so i've
shot in jpeg now i'm gonna shoot this in
raw and we're gonna see what this looks
like as well now to go into raw you have
to go into the more option here and then
go into hasselblad
has an acid the hasselblad logo with pro
the wide angle
good
we're going to go into this and we're
going to do ultra high res
ultra high res is going to take multiple
photos and stack them together
and there's a lot of detail on that
okay
so that's pretty much it for the oppo
find x5 pro got to say the image on the
screen looks fantastic of course we're
going to lightroom we'll take a look at
those images now let's try out with the
xiaomi 12 pro so now we're using the
xiaomi 12 pro now here's the interesting
thing about these cameras all three
lenses are 50 megapixel cameras
so in theory we should be getting pretty
much the same image quality no matter
for an ultra wide wide or telephoto
we'll try that out right now with the
same situation as we are with the opal
find x5 pro the same scenery to see how
it renders colors details all that great
stuff so let's try this out real quick
we're now just in basic photo mode no
raw everything's turned off
and uh
let's see what it looks like here
there you are zac look at that
the colors are very saturated on this
the reds are just screaming off the
screen on this one it is really bright
the blues as well
so
the oppo had a little bit more of a
natural look to it this looks a little
bit more accentuated everyone's gonna
have their own preference on what they
like but this is just what i'm seeing on
the screen of course when we go into
lightroom there may be a difference on
that as well
now zacky is modeling this
backpack here
we're going to porch remote on that
does a decent job of
detecting him but some of the hair is a
little bit blurry in that regard
yeah this one i would say the portrait
mode
is not as good
as the oppo i think the opal has got a
better hand when it comes to the
portrait mode on this
go to 50 megapixel version
50 megapixel version looks good as well
i mean a little bit more dynamic range
in that regard but i would say it's
still more
saturated
i will say this when
you're using the raw mode of the pro
mode on the xiaomi the images tend to
look a lot better than with using the
center jpeg and just letting it do its
thing
so that's something to take note of on
that now with the s22 ultra we have four
cameras versus three cameras like the
other two phones
and uh so we're probably gonna get
better image quality when we go into the
telephoto or ultra wide angle
versus
the xiaomi or the opal or will we not
let's find out let's think of the
standard photo here uh
see let's move away here i'm going to
take a photo of this area now right off
the bat
this is not as saturated as
the oppo or the uh xiaomi for that
matter the colors are more muted i would
say they look more muted than what i'm
seeing in real life
plenty of detail there's a lot of detail
in these images here i will say though
the samsung and the oppo are really neck
and neck when it comes to portrait mode
in terms of that realistic bokeh from
the your subject being in focus into the
background being out of focus
they do a decent job separating the
hairs you could give the edge to samsung
a little bit in this regard but i think
the oboe is right there as well now
let's try with uh
the wide angle portrait mode
so now we're just going to test out raw
real quick on the s22 ultra now here's
the thing you need to download a
separate app to shoot in raw which is
ridiculous
you shouldn't need to all the other
phones have it built into the app system
but here you don't so anyway
it is what it is as they say let's do go
to expert raw mode
because this raw takes multiple images
to stack it
okay
taking a while there
all right so that's pretty much it with
the raw feature of it it's a little slow
probably it's a little bit buggy uh it's
unfortunate i would expect more from
samsung in that regard but maybe
there'll be a software update anyway
we're running low on battery here we're
gonna go back to the studio we're gonna
test out video mode and i'll come back
with my final thoughts but in the
meantime here's a message from our
sponsor
this video is brought to you by secret
lab here at geek culture we love our
secret lab chairs especially the all-new
2022 titan evo with its revamped 4-way
lumbar system for enhanced back support
if you leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea
then consider the all-new soft weave
even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colors
including this lovely frost blue the
titan evo is even magnetized allowing
the head pillow to stick on the headrest
without straps of course there are even
more new features so do check them out
at secretlab.com
all right guys we're now in lightroom
taking a look at images here from the
oppo the samsung and the xiaomi phones
if you've been sticking with us this
long thank you so much for watching we
put a lot of work in this video it's
probably one of our longest we've done
on the channel thus far okay let's get
into it let's look at the oppo first um
let's take a look at this jpeg image
here of zacky
and uh these are somewhat simple images
just more for a sample than anything
else but looking at this real quick we
can take on a zoom in on this there's a
lot of detail here and i think the image
and jpeg works relatively well here iso
100 is 6.25 millimeters at 4.5 went over
160th of a second at j shot in jpeg
looks good right now this course has
been edited slightly this is before and
this is after before and after i really
just adjusted the highlights and a
little bit of the exposure for the most
part because the colors are bang on
they're fantastic
now let's go over to a
dng file here
from the oppo because all these phones
do shoot in dng for the most part
samsung is more very interesting in the
sense that you have to download a
separate app we'll get to that in just a
bit but anyway let's look at
the oppo here
and as you can see i mean it's pretty
decent and now the jpegs will be
naturally sharper when you are shooting
in raw or dng for that matter you will
notice the images are softer you see
this on the xiaomi as well and also in
the samsung but it does a decent job and
there's a lot of information here again
iso 100 5.97 millimeters f 1.7 went over
1700 of a second uh this is pretty much
set on the camera as it is and it looks
good i mean
yeah no complaints at all not as sharp
as the jpeg but again do you need to
shoot in raw for a smartphone it really
depends on your application but i'm
overall pleasantly surprised and here's
the uh would it look like before and
here's after okay let's go to a couple
of ranges here this is a me and this was
shooting in x-pan mode now x-pan mode
only shoots in jpeg but i do like the
images that come out of this and uh
looking at the detail right here it is
sharp i mean a little bit over sharpened
happen you could probably say if you
want to be a little bit nitpicky but i
think for
jpegs it does a decent job and of course
when you're looking at things in
lightroom you're going to see all
of the flaws in all the images here
because again these are developed to be
seen on a smartphone a display versus a
laptop or a computer display like i have
here but it looks good no issues at all
with that like the colors are coming out
of it very happy and i love the x-pan in
black and white i just absolutely love
the way this looks has a very film-esque
look to it and i love this 65 by 24
aspect ratio ratios just absol
absolutely awesome it looks great look
at the detail in there sharp eyebrows
beard hair you can see it all right
there
very happy with the end result on that
and here's a couple more here's zacky
we're at a coffee shop here
and you can see it's a little bit over
sharpened here on the eyeglasses but it
looks good still great for posting on
social media no issues at all as i
mentioned looking in lightroom you are
going to see something different than
what you're going to see on the
smartphone um display and you can
definitely see here and there's a lot of
detail that these uh these cameras do
cover because they're pretty much all
well stacked up okay now let's look at
the xiaomi selects here now we did get
some shots of zacky here in various
different poses let's take a look real
quick here
uh this is
shot in dng
and we go on this
it's decent not too bad a little soft
but as i mentioned dng will
you know it will be softer than jpeg
because there's a lot of correction
happening with the jpegs but it's a
decent job and you can actually play
along with the files a little bit if you
want to get into that you know drop the
highlights down a little bit bring the
exposure in if you want to boost up the
contrast slightly just to give a little
bit more pop
a little bit of vibrance actually to it
there it looks good no complaints at all
and of course
that's how it looks in a dng file let's
look at a jpeg here of zacky giving me
the
hand on the neck pose look at this hand
on the neck pose
iso 50 7.1 millimeters f 1.9 one over
one eightieth of a second zero these are
all auto settings inside the camera so
it is what it is this has been edited
slightly this is before and this is
after before and after again colors are
really good i mean it's slightly a
little bit overexposed on that that's
how the camera renders it but again you
can adjust that very easily in any sort
of
you know post-production software that
you have here and i'm happy with it um
compared to
the oppo
i would say the oppo's got slightly more
detail to it in my personal opinion
slightly more detail
but as it stands i mean these are very
relatively close and
you know what both cameras are really
good but i would give the edge to the
oppo in that regard
okay let's look at a couple other images
here let's look at this uh picture of my
volkswagen tiguan this is of course in
portrait mode here and i gotta say the
portrait mode in this and is really good
actually does it detect the lines
relatively well it does a good job you
are gonna see flaring coming off of
smartphone lenses no matter what camera
you use on what phone you're going to
see some sort of flaring if you use it
correctly it can be sort of artistic but
it can also be a pain in the butt but i
have to say look at the detail on this
i'm really happy with the end results
this is very sharp for a smartphone
right here and this is a jpeg iso 99 iso
99 who would have thought but xiaomi
gives it to you it looks really good
this has been edited slightly let me
show you the before let me this is the
after before and after sort of you know
made it a little bit more autumn with
the leaves here but really happy with it
again the portrait mode is absolutely
fantastic the nice fall off coming off
to the back of the tiguan here to the
front where it's sharp this looks really
natural very happy okay and here's
another shot here of this outside the
car as i was driving
look at the colors out of this was
absolutely awesome and again this is
kind of what it looked like i mean this
is before and this is after before
after kind of accentuated the blues a
little bit but we had a beautiful sunset
happening here accentuated some of the
colors give a little bit more vibrancy a
little bit more pop
and this is iso 282 and this is on the
wide angle lens and it's pretty good i
have to say not too bad at all
definitely usable for social media of
course when you want to zoom in on this
you're going to see some smear smudging
and some a little bit of distortion here
but again i'm shooting on my windshield
so it's not going to be as sharp as if i
was not doing so but i'm happy with the
overall image and how it looks all right
and
yeah these are just a couple other ones
exactly posing with this backpack here
dng file
and yeah it's a little bit soft on here
you know this is the interesting thing
about this the camera says doesn't focus
but when you look at it here on the
computer it's not but anyway this is uh
the results that we got uh firmware will
be updated on these phones pretty
regularly so
i mean look for improvements to be
happening here of course we were testing
this phone right when it was launched
with the you know the first version of
the firmware out there so it will get
better as we go on but yeah you can see
it's a little bit soft here not optimal
but
again it's a dng okay let's go to the
samsung images here real quick and then
we'll go to our final thoughts okay now
we are in the samsung s22 ultras um
selects here again we're trying
different poses here but nonetheless all
the same lighting this is zacky right
here between the two chairs
giving them that
ultimate zoolander look here this was a
jpeg
this was shot in portrait mode and it's
absolutely beautiful look at the fall
off but here's one thing i really like
about the samsung swing to ultra and i
did notice this in the oppo as well
good separation for the hair here it's
not perfect it's not like you're using a
normal camera but it's pretty good for a
smartphone um a lot of detail here great
colors coming out of this uh here's what
it looks like before and after before
after just just a slight edit just to
kind of give a little bit of more oomph
to the image but very happy with the
results on that
okay here's a close-up of zacky again a
little bit blurry on this dng versus
jpeg something you're going to notice in
all three of these phones dng is
slightly softer
i would say the dng out of this one
not as good as the oppo
and probably very on par with the xiaomi
it could be slightly under i don't know
it's really close but again you know you
can play around with that a little bit
more here's the dng file as well a
little bit blurred out
um
this is just happening with these phones
folks so nothing i can do with that so
it says in focus you go with that and
that's what the end result is so if dng
is not really doing any sort of
post-processing to the images
then this is what you're actually
getting out of the camera system i will
say this i don't have the iphone 13 pro
in this comparison but the iphone 13
pro's raw images are better than what
i'm seeing here out of all these three
thus far again maybe we'll do a
comparison in the near future but if
you're just wondering those are my
thoughts on that and here's just this
night shot here at this uh top of this
rooftop here in dng again softer gives
you some room to play with if you want
to play with the highlights and shadows
a little bit more you know you're going
to blow out the lights right there but
you've got some room to play with in in
this regard versus the jpeg which would
probably break up a little bit sooner
but again if you're looking for
sharpness and detail you might be
lacking a little bit all right guys
those are the samples from the samsung
now let's go to my final thoughts on
these three phones all right so here's a
video test we're at the geek culture
studios here how we normally shoot a lot
of our reviews but we're using the opal
find x5 pro this is in 4k with ai on
it's going to give you a sense with
optimal lighting how the image quality
can be and if it will replace where you
know replace your normal camera if you
want to do some video
so this is what it looks like and then
zac you'll turn off ai now this is what
the footage looks like so if you see a
difference or not i can't see anything
right now but of course you'll be able
to see it in the video sample here on
screen to see if the difference is but
of course ai will help in some regards
in some ways they can impede the image
it depends on your preference but
it's an option for you now you can't do
flat or any sort of log profile
unfortunately that's not available in
the native apps of course you can use
filmic pro and things like that you can
download those apps and utilize it but
as it stands right now in the oppo app
it's just the standard color uh
scientists coming out of the uh
hasselblad combination with the opal
find x5 pro i prefer we love the ai
though it's more natural more natural
without the ai and you've got details
there yeah we want details details are
important now one of the cool features
of the oppo find x5 pro is actually the
film mode now this is gives you more
let's call it like professional video
mode
and you have active steady shot in this
which will crop in when we turn that off
because we're here on a tripod in the
studio but it also allows you to shoot
in log or hdr now you have to choose
between the two now we're shooting a log
right now which exactly will then color
grade it and see how this looks but this
gives you a really nice option that you
don't necessarily get in a lot of
smartphone cameras out there you usually
have to download separate apps to do
this but opal's put this inside of
the uh find x5 pro which makes it very
interesting for videographers out there
we tried this on the xperia pro i with
not the greatest success but how does
this look let us know your thoughts
below alright so now we're testing out
the xiaomi 12 pro no hdr no hlg this is
straight out of camera in 4k now of
course this can do 8k as well but we're
not going to be showing ak in this test
we'll show it in just a bit but uh yeah
that's what the image quality looks like
of course with lighting here in the
studio so now we're testing out the hdr
video on this and you do lose that box
where you have the focus tracking on my
face but i mean i seem to be in focus so
far
and uh
which one do you prefer hdr or non-hdr
let us know and then we'll try hlg as
well just in case you want to see what
that looks like so here is hdr 10 plus
and
yeah i mean hdr 10 plus can be a little
bit much for some some people will enjoy
it also depends on your editing software
it can handle the uh the imaging on this
now we do know that premiere pro can
have some issues with hdr at times
uh or any other editing software so keep
that in mind if you want to put this
onto your you know your timeline if
you're editing on final cut premiere
whatever the case may be you may have to
make some adjustments
but uh you know if you're just going to
be publishing online you know right out
of camera it could be okay what are your
thoughts which do you prefer hdr 10 plus
but let's try hlg now and see what are
the differences are
so here's what hlg looks like on the
xiaomi 12 pro now this is something
interesting with a smartphone to have
hlg or hdr10 plus inside of it xiaomi is
trying to give you the best of all
worlds with video but it's up to your
discretion which one do you like do you
prefer non-hdr hdr 10 plus or hlg let us
know in the comment section below so now
we're testing out video on the s22 ultra
in 4k now here's something interesting
on the wide-angle lens or the standard
lens it's wider than the other two
because you have four lenses on this
versus three so samsung is giving you
options for the wide angle you got ultra
wide angle wide angle telephoto and
super telephoto or however terminologies
you want to put to it but you have four
lenses regardless but how does the video
look now we don't have hdr turned on
everything is basic
and now we're going to try on some other
modes to see which video option is
better for you on this regard so now
we're testing out hdr 10 plus in 4k now
as you can tell by the image i'm a
little bit more overexposed on this of
course you can adjust this if you want
but out of camera you are going to see
this but it also has this sort of auto
framing mode so if i move to the extreme
left
or the extreme right
it should be tracking me a little bit to
keep me in center frame now if i just
move a little bit you're not going to
notice a difference but if you do
extreme movements
you'll get that it's kind of a cool
feature and uh you know but each their
own so what do you think which do you
prefer hdr10 plus or
non-hdr let us know now one of the key
attributes of the s22 ultra is these
various different video modes so if you
really want to get into vlogging more
creative videography you have director
view view modes in this inside that so
um these are really cool features but
not everybody will utilize them and this
is something you have to ask yourself
before purchasing one of these phones
will you take advantage of some of these
more advanced features that samsung is
offering or will you go with more some
of the basic features
that uh oppo or xiaomi is offering as
well i mean they all pretty much have
most of the features and those apps out
there that can give you a lot of these
as well so it's really depends on the
phone that you like and the image
quality that you like the best but i
have to say samsung does pack these
phones up with some really interesting
features for the videographers and
photographers out there all right guys
as you saw from the lightroom portion
and the video samples out there each of
these phones have their strengths and
their weaknesses
and there's no
best phone out there just depends in
terms of what you like out of the camera
systems now the samsung gives you four
cameras it gives you the best video on
the front-facing camera out of all the
other systems out there
but it's a much larger phone and it's a
much more expensive phone xiaomi and
opal are kind of neck and neck in a lot
of ways but i would give the edge to
oppo when it comes to camera features
especially with the hasselblad
partnership now of course we're all
seeing this with the oneplus series and
hasselblad of course is working with
oppo they're kind of the same company
guys you know what i mean so you are
going to see that partnership carry
through but i do love the expand feature
i think it's very unique i love the film
mode where you can shoot and log it's
built into the camera system this gives
you options if you are a videographer
out there to grade it if you'd like to
do so and i do love the color science
that's coming out of the camera system
it does remind me a lot of what i'm
shooting out of the x1d and x1d2
uh from the hasselblad and i really love
those
that color science now it is a little
bit more saturated a little more vibrant
out of a phone but you can tone that
down in post like i did in lightroom
overall it's gonna be a hard choice to
make and it's dependent on your budget
but i would say the most fun i had out
of these three did come out of the oppo
find x5 pro but those are my thoughts
let me know your thoughts in the
comments section below do you agree with
me any questions you have on these
camera systems i'll try to answer those
for you with that guys take care stay
safe subscribe to the channel and we
will chat to you soon take care
[Music]
you